hi I'm Anthony Mason I'm gonna be
joining Gayle King and Tony Duke opal as
a co-host on CBS this morning
I have a very diverse family my my mom
was an interior decorator my stepfather
was a painter my father was basically a
Wall Street stockbroker so I have a I
have a have a very broad series of
influences all of which you know came
into play as I was growing up I
basically got my start at TV because my
father kind of kicked me out of the
house I came home from college having no
idea what I was gonna do I was an
English major in a government minor but
I had no job prospects my lap father
looked at me about two weeks after I
moved into the back end of that his
house and said what are you gonna do
with the rest of your life and I said
I'm gonna write a novel and dad said not
in this house and that led to my father
frantically trying to figure out where
he could soar which direction he could
kind of push his son to get him out of
his hair and out of the house one thing
led to another and I ended up with a job
at KJR htv-2 in Tulsa Oklahoma which was
the best thing that ever happened to me
everything all the fundamentals that I
learned in television I learned there
from some really great people getting up
in the mornings there's no question that
was going to be the hardest part of this
job it is the only thing that made me
I've never really been a morning person
so that part's not gonna be easy I
usually set two alarms I might set three
just to be sure but you know you get
into a rhythm eventually I hope so they
tell me that's what I love most about
that show and part of what I have a big
part of why I wanted to do it was
there's a great energy in that room
there's a is a huge floor crew there's a
lot of people when when there's a couple
of exciting guests there's a just a
fabulous buzz that I've always enjoyed
being part of when I'm when I'm on the
show and when I've been on the show when
it's happened I love those days it's
what I've always loved about television
sort of the excitement that you're
making something with a lot of really
creative people and that room is really
special it always has been one of the
things that's most exciting about this
is is I have enormous respect for both
of my co-hosts you know Tony is
relatively new at CBS but he's he's an
incredibly talented guy and and I've
I've really been impressed by what I've
seen so far and a very smart guy who's
already seen a lot of things in life
Gale who I first met you know filling in
on CBS this morning about seven years
ago the minute I sat down next to her I
was kind of blown away by how how much
herself she really wasn't
but the Gayle King you see on TV is
absolutely the Gayle King that I know
she's no different and that it's not
easy to be yourself on television
because it's pretty scary with everybody
watching and in that respect somebody
who watched the show said to me once I
think I think Gayle is brave and I was
like you're right because it's very hard
to be purely yourself and and she is and
and I've I sent her a note after I work
with it the first time and I said I have
an enormous I have an enormous respect
for what you do and it's you know I'm
I'm kind of awed by it and
excited at the same time because I
realized there's things I can still
really learn even at at my age and I
like to continue learning so I'm really
looking forward working with Gayle who I
think of as one of the finest
broadcasters of our time and with Tony
who is an exceptional up-and-coming
journalist and broadcaster I we like
each other already which makes it a lot
easier and and I think it's gonna be a
lot of fun
tomorrow you'll hear from my colleague
Gayle King and we're all really looking
forward to seeing you on Monday May 20th
when we debut on CBS this morning